[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going to talk about some of my
discoveries around the world through my
work these are not discoveries of
planets or new technologies or science
they're discoveries of people and the
way people are and new leadership
this is binky binky is a leader of the a
Shaniqua nation his people live in
Brazil and in Peru
binky comes from a village so remote up
in the Amazon that to get there either
you have to fly and land on water or go
by canoe for several days I met binky
three years ago in San Paolo when I
brought him and other leaders from
indigenous peoples to meet with me and
leaders from around the world because he
wanted to learn from each other we
wanted to share our stories with each
other the action Inca people are known
throughout South America for their
dignity their spirit and their
resistance starting with the Incas and
continuing through the 19th century with
the rubber tappers today's biggest
threats to the Astra Nica people anta
Behnke comes from illegal logging the
people who come into the beautiful
forest and cut down ancient mahogany
trees float them down the river to
rolled markets binky knew this he could
see what was happening to his forests to
his environment because he was taken
under his grandfather's wing when he was
only 2 years old to begin to learn about
the forest and the way of life of his
people his grandfather died when he was
only 10 and at that young age ten years
old
binky became the padre of his community
now in the ashen Inca tradition and
culture the Padre is the most important
person in the community this is the
person who contains within him all the
knowledge all the wisdom of centuries
and centuries of life and not just about
his people but about
everything that his people survival
depended on the trees the birds the
water the soil the forest so when he was
only ten and he became the Padre he
began to lead his people he began to
talk to them about the forest that they
needed to protect the way of life they
needed to nurture he explained to them
that it was not a question of survival
of the fittest it was a question of
understanding what they needed to
survive and to protect that eight years
later when he was a young man of
eighteen benke left the forest for the
first time he went 3,000 miles on an
odyssey to Rio to the Earth Summit to
tell the world what was happening in his
tiny little corner and he went because
he hoped the world would listen some did
not everybody but if you can imagine
this young man with his headdress and
his flowing robe learning a new language
Portuguese not to mention English going
to Rio building a bridge to reach out to
people he'd never met before a pretty
hostile world but he wasn't just made
bank he came back to his village full of
ideas new technologies new research new
ways of understanding what was going on
since that time he's continued to work
with his people and not only the a
Shaniqua nation but all the peoples of
the Amazon and beyond he's built schools
to teach children to care for the forest
together he's led the reforestation of
over 25 percent of the land that had
been destroyed by the loggers he's
created a cooperative to help people
diversify their livelihoods and he's
brought the internet and satellite
technology to the forest both so the
people themselves could monitor the
deforestation but also so that they
could speak from the forest to the rest
of the world if you were to meet binky
and ask him why are you doing this why
are you putting yourself at risk why are
you making yourself vulnerable to what
is often a hostile world
he would tell you as he told me I asked
myself he said what did my grandparents
and my great-grandparents do to protect
the forest for me and what am i doing so
when I think of that I wonder what our
grandchildren and our
great-grandchildren when they ask
themselves that question I wonder how
they will answer for me the world is
veering towards a future we don't munch
once when we really think about it deep
inside it's a future we don't know the
details of but it's a future that has
signs just like binky saw the signs
around him we know we are running out of
what we need we're running out of fresh
water we're running out of fossil fuels
we're running out of land we know
climate change is going to affect all of
us we don't know how but we know it will
and we know that there will be more of
us than ever before five times as many
people in 40 years than 60 years ago we
are running out of what we need and we
also know that the world has changed in
other ways that since 1960 there are
one-third as many new countries that
exist as independent entities on the
planet
egos systems of government figuring it
out massive change and in addition to
that we know that five other really big
countries are going to have a say in the
future I say we haven't even really
started to hear yet China India Russia
South Africa and Benke zone Brazil where
B&T got his civil rights only in the
1988 Constitution but you know all that
you know more than binky knew when he
left his forest and went 3,000 miles you
also know that we can't just keep doing
what we've always done because we'll get
the results we've always gotten and this
reminds me of something I understand
Lord Salisbury said to Queen Victoria
over a hundred years ago when she was
pressing him please change
he said change why change things are bad
enough as they are we have to change
it's imperative to me when I look around
the world that we need we need to change
ourselves we need new models of what it
means to be a leader we need new models
of being a leader and a human in the
world I started life as a banker now I
don't admit to that to anybody but my
very close friends but for the past
eight years I've done something
completely different my work has taken
me around the world where I've had the
real privilege of meeting people like
Venky and many others who are making
change happen in their communities
people who see the world differently who
are asking different questions who have
different answers who understand the
filters that they wear when they go out
into the world
this is Sanghamitra Sanghamitra comes
from Bangalore
I met Sanghamitra eight years ago when I
was in Bangalore organizing a workshop
with leaders of different NGOs working
on some of the hardest aspects of
society Sankar Mitra didn't start life
as a leader of an NGO she started her
career as a university professor
teaching English literature but she
realized that she was much too detached
from the world doing that she loved it
but she was too detached and so in 1993
a long time ago she decided to start a
new organization called Sam Ranck siya
focused on one of the hardest areas one
of the hardest issues in India anywhere
in the world at the time hiv/aids
since that time Sam Ranck siya has grown
from strength to strength and is now one
of the leading health in G o--'s in
India but if you just think about the
state of the world and knowledge of
hiv/aids in 1993 in India at that time
it was skyrocketing and nobody
understood why and everyone was actually
very very afraid today there are still
three million HIV
positive people in India that's the
second largest population in the world
when I asked Sankar media how did you
get from English literature to hiv/aids
not an obvious path she said to me it's
all connected
literature makes one sensitive sensitive
to people to their dreams and to their
ideas since that time under her
leadership some rank she has been a
pioneer in all fields related to
hiv/aids
they have respite homes the first the
first care centers the first counselling
services and not just an urban seven
million population Bangalore but in the
hardest to reach villages in the state
of Karnataka even that wasn't enough she
wanted to change policy at the
government level ten of their programs
that she pioneered are now government
policy and funded by the government they
take care of 20,000 odd people today in
over 1,000 villages around Karnataka she
works with people like Murali Krishna
Murali Krishna comes from one of those
villages he lost his wife to AIDS a
couple of years ago and he's HIV
positive but he saw the work the care
the compassion that sangra Mitra and her
team brought to the village and he
wanted to be part of it
he's a leaders quest fellow and that
helps him with his work
they've pioneered a different approach
to villages instead of handing out
information and pamphlets as is so often
the case they bring theater troupes
songs music dance and they sit around
and they talk about dreams Sanghamitra
told me just last week she had just come
back from two weeks in the villages and
she had a real breakthrough they were
sitting in a circle talking about the
dreams for the village and the young
women in the village spoke up and said
we've changed our dream our dream is for
our partners our husbands not to be
given to us because of a horoscope but
to be given to us because they've been
tested for HIV if you were lucky enough
to meet Sanghamitra
and ask her why and how how have you
achieved so much she would look at you
and very quietly very softly say it just
happened
it's the spirit inside this is dr. fan
John chuan John chuan comes from Sichuan
Province in southwest China he was born
in 1957 and you can imagine what his
childhood looked like and felt like and
what his life has been like over the
last 50 to multi-with years he's been a
soldier a teacher a politician a vice
mayor and a businessman but if you sat
down and asked him who are you really
and what do you do he would tell you I'm
a collector and I curate an Museum I was
lucky I had heard about him for years
and I finally met him earlier this year
at his Museum and Chengdu he's been a
collector all of his life starting when
he was four or five in the early 1960s
and I just think of the early 1960s in
China over a lifetime through everything
through the Cultural Revolution and
everything afterwards he's kept
collecting so that he now has over eight
million pieces in his museums
documenting contemporary Chinese history
these are pieces that you won't find
anywhere else in the world and part
because they document parts of history
Chinese choose to forget for example
he's got over 1 million pieces
documenting the sino-japanese war a war
that's not talked about in China very
much and whose heroes are not honored
why did he do all this because he
thought a nation should never repeat the
mistakes of the past
so from commissioning slightly larger
than life bronze statues of the heroes
of the sino-japanese war including those
Chinese who then fought with each other
and left mainland China to go to Taiwan
to commemorating all the unknown
ordinary soldiers who survived by
asking them to take prints of their
hands he is making sure one man is
making sure that history is not
forgotten but it's not just Chinese
heroes he cares about this building
contains the world's largest collection
of documents and artifacts commemorating
the u.s. role in fighting on the Chinese
side in that long war the Flying Tigers
he has nine other buildings that are
already open to the public
filled to the rafters with artifacts
documenting contemporary Chinese history
to the most sensitive buildings include
a lifetime of collection about the
Cultural Revolution a period that
actually most Chinese would prefer to
forget but he doesn't want his nation
ever do you forget these people inspire
me and they inspire me because they show
us what is possible when you change the
way you look at the world change the way
you look at your place in the world they
looked outside and then they changed
what was on the inside they didn't go to
business school they didn't read a
manual how to be a good leader in ten
easy steps but they have qualities we'd
all recognize they have Drive passion
commitment they've gone away from what
they did before and they've gone to
something they didn't know they've tried
to connect worlds they didn't know
existed before they've built bridges and
they've walked across them they have a
sense of the great arc of time and their
tiny place in it they know people have
come before them and will follow them
and they know that they're part of a
whole that they depend on other people
it's not about them they know that but
it has to start with them and they have
humility
it just happens but we know it doesn't
just happen don't we we know it takes a
lot to make it happen and we know the
direction the world is going in so I
think we need succession planning on a
global basis
we can't wait for the next generation
the new joiners to come in and learn how
to be the good leaders we need I think
it has to start with us and we know just
like they knew how hard it is but the
good news is that we don't have to
figure it out as we go along we have
models we have examples like binky and
Sanghamitra and John chuan we can look
at what they've done if we look we can
learn from what they've learned we can
change the way we see ourselves in the
world and if we're lucky we can change
the way our great-grandchildren will
answer pinky's question thank you
[Applause]
[Music]